bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors les talibans disent
contrôler 90 % du territoire afghan
même plus l'armée afghane dément qu'en
est-il de l'avancée des talibans
aujourd'hui qui ont commencé leur
offensive il ya des mois maintenant
il savait tout les toutes les
observations convergent pour créditer
l'idée qu'effectivement les talibans
sont en train de conquérir la la grande
majorité du pays 90 % 80 % n'en sait
trop rien mais ce qui est sûr s'il
voulait c'est qu'aujourd'hui ils sont
très clairement en position de force
comme ils ne l'ont jamais été depuis des
décennies et on sait dire que ce conflit
est un confit de longue durée dont on
assiste aujourd'hui aux toutes dernières
péripéties
alors il ya des miliciens
pro-gouvernementaux qui est
manifestement soutiennent le
gouvernement en tout cas elles sont
contre les talibans
qui sont-ils et doit-on se soucier de
leur présence voilà je crois que de
toute façon c'est un problème que les
afghans eux mêmes auront à résoudre
puisque il y a dans ce pays aujourd'hui
on voit bien des forces antagonistes il
y à un certain nombre de milices qui
parfois ont une coloration ethnique ou
religieuse et qui sont plus ou moins lié
avec les forces du gouvernement en place
ce gouvernement d'ailleurs qui est
largement sous perfusion occidentale
depuis des années des années c'est un
peu le problème de ce pays si vous
voulez c'est que l'intervention
militaire occidentale étasunienne
d'abord puis avec un certain nombre de
partenaires états unis a créé une
situation vous avez un gouvernement fait
qu'il n'est pas représentatif du pays
quoi qu'on pense des différentes
factions qui se battent en afghanistan
il est clair qu'on a une situation où le
gouvernement représente davantage de
pays légal que le pays réel donc toutes
les forces qui joue un rôle aujourd'hui
dans le conflit qui hélas en semblant de
ce pays vont compter demain d'une
manière ou d'une autre dans je dirais
une nouvelle redistribution du pouvoir
c'est inévitable c'est une question qui
revient souvent c'est lorsque l'armée
américaine repart d'afghanistan les
talibans reviennent en force qu'elle a
été
l'utilité et l'efficacité de leur
présence sur le territoire afghan
l'efficacité de 20 ans de présence
américaine n'est même pas nul
elle est négative en fait si vous voulez
en fait cette intervention militaire n'a
apporté que le désordre le chaos et la
misère à ce pays ce qui montre une fois
de plus que les interventions militaires
occidentales dans des pays dont les
affaires d'ailleurs ne regarde pas
l'occident sont toujours toujours à
l'origine de catastrophes qui sont pires
que les mots qu'on a prétendu vouloir
éviter donc c'est une leçon à tirer je
pense pour toutes les puissances qui se
sont engagés dans ce conflit et
notamment pour les etats-unis c'est que
non seulement ça ne sert à rien mais si
seulement ça ne servait qu'à rien si
mais c'est pire que ça sacré en fait les
germes d'un conflit encore plus aiguë et
de souffrance encore plus importantes
pour les populations
là il ya vraiment une motion à tirer je
crois pourrons pour les états unis et
tous ceux qui se sont engagés dans cette
aventure
on sait qu'il ya eu des négociations et
des pourparlers entre les talibans et le
gouvernement afghan et d'autres
intervenants est ce que vous croyez
encore en une résolution diplomatique
est ce que c'est encore possible
on s'est trop tard vu l'avancé militaire
des talibans alors que un certain nombre
de puissances extérieures et pas
seulement d'ailleurs des états unis ou
les pays occidentaux mais on a vu
dernièrement la chine et c'est par le
dialogue et la négociation y compris des
talibans bien sûr de favoriser une issue
pacifique ou un compromis ou une formule
de coalition enfin je ne sais pas
quelque chose qui ressemblerait à ça ce
n'est pas en soi une mauvaise chose
surtout si les intentions de ces
puissances sont des intentions qui
tombent pas mauvaise bon il est évident
par exemple que la chine avait cherché à
sécuriser sa frontière elle souhaite que
l'afghanistan retrouve une certaine
forme de paix de stabilité à comprendre
cet exemple par contre ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur du pays est préoccupant
parce qu'en réalité jamais les
différentes factions qui se partagent le
territoire ne sont parvenus à un accord
durable
il ya quand même une dimension ronge
afghano afghanes dans ce conflit qui ne
faut pas négliger c'est que ça toujours
été quand même depuis pas mal de temps
avant même l'intervention des
soviétiques ou des américains ou
d'autres partenaires ou intervenants une
terre sur laquelle si vous voulez les
différentes factions se sont toujours
combattu et ça c'est un pro
qu'il faut pas nier le caractère
endogène du conflit afghan et les
talibans contrôlent aujourd'hui 80 à 90%
en tout cas la majorité du territoire
afghan
est ce que c'est une question de jours
de mois pour qu'ils prennent le contrôle
total du pays en tout cas de kaboul ce
qui leur permettrait de prendre le
pouvoir
c'est difficile à dire inconnue l'une
est en mesure de lire dans le marc de
café et là par contre bon question de
jours peut-être pas question de mois
certainement c'est à dire que on voit
bien aujourd'hui que le rapport de
forces est en faveur de du mouvement
taliban qui finalement a résisté à
l'intervention militaire étrangère qui
s'est même nourri de l'intervention
militaire étrangère parce qu'elle va
donner une sorte de dire si vous voulez
de légitimité nationale 1 outre la
légitimité islamique dans ce mouvances
réclament la légitimité nationale
on a transformé ce mouvement en
véritable mouvement de résistance en
réalité en prétendant libérer les
afghans malgré eux et donc aujourd'hui
sont en position de force dont il semble
acquis que les talibans effectivement
puisse prendre le pouvoir à brève et
moyenne échéance bon augure merci en
tout cas d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes analyste
géopolitique merci